[Music]
do me a favor promise me this because
everyone's following you right now and
sorry they're gonna tell me tomorrow
that you [ __ ] I know yeah it's over
[ __ ] now we've got everyone's watching
make an Instagram video where you just
talk about things so I'm just riding
this [ __ ] wave that Gary Vee just
created cuz I know you [ __ ] will
destroy me if I don't do this so you
know I'm talking quarantined and bored
as [ __ ] so let's do this [ __ ]
you've got your prospective hey Gary
hey Laura how are you good I'm so
excited to be on with you so I have like
a million questions so I was trying to
like comply
so I more or less want to be a writer as
my career I've had a travel blog since
2008 I wrote a book last year I kind of
did everything self-published I wanted
to learn everything I kind of want to
learn the ropes of it all so I'm so I
love that it's great but the sales are
not there I mean I sold like 65 Coffee
is just my own marketing and all that
stuff and what my own platform and all
that but I have a second one and I'm not
sure what to do with it because you're
worried about the sales I'm worried
about the sales but I'm also like I want
to get it out there like I want this to
really be my career and I'm not sure if
this is like because I get stuck out
like I have been doing this for 12 years
so like maybe this is something like is
this something like I should keep going
with or is it like okay well you know 12
years is a real at-bat like I'm proud of
you yeah you persevered and hung in like
this is tough to say but sometimes maybe
not there's a lot of people who want to
be a rapper and they're not good enough
there's me I want to be actors and not
good enough there's people that want to
be writers and not good enough now you
know I'm mister optimist but I'm also
mister practical
I don't think that has to be a bad thing
let me tell you why I think the energy
of it not working for this for this
period of time you see in a lot of ways
sometimes becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy of not letting it happen I
believe that if you go and try to jam on
some other stuff that also makes you
happy
creative sometimes that becomes the
unlock all the sudden like I can see a
scenario where you start like sucking
starting up our podcast because
ironically you also like flowers they're
pretty tivity gets going a little
something but then that triggers the
creativity you start buying yourself two
years later starting to write a little
bit and then that popped off what you're
doing yeah I mean I started writing on
elephant journal - well the different
type of writing because that I don't
travel like I used to I started this
about 18 so I'm 30 now so I've changed
so much and those than that period of
time so I actually enjoy that type of
writing where my website is now where
it's I have my travel when I can and
then I write also whatever I want to
write about but like my main thing about
my books is like how to deal with
anxiety and like how much how much free
content are you putting out on the
internet with you in video form talking
about those subject matters I actually
eat video why I I'm just not a video
person like not your video personally no
you're doing extremely well I know but I
eat it loving it self-conscious about
your looks
no it's not that I just don't feel like
I have like the personality or going
I really don't you're wrong yeah you've
decided that for yourself subjectively
yeah yeah I mean yeah I guess it's just
it's not I guess it's uncomfortable for
me to kind of like talk to myself you
know what I mean yeah so what you could
do is actually start a zoom aura or live
you could go live where there's other
people like right now Jerry Young's here
and Suns already and late and that makes
me feel more comfortable like what about
like Brian be like maybe I mean I I
couldn't disagree with you more I've
I've done this a ton and recognize when
people are wildly uncomfortable with
video yeah you've arbitrarily from it in
secure place weren't a subject the place
or an ideology a place or just a random
thought place I've decided that yeah but
didn't you say two of them cuz I'm like
followed you for so many years and I'm
like huge on your content like if that's
not your strong suit
should you not join that's what cuz
right that's right but I've got a
problem with that yeah
you've given writing 12 years you've
given video zero [ __ ] days yeah I
don't know if it's your strong suit and
guess who else doesn't know you right
yeah no I got it
well good cuz that's some real [ __ ] like
no good that's a fun moment you might be
right I'm just intuitive about this and
feel like you could definitely talk to
the video camera yeah and we just have
to like you know I'm sure it's
uncomfortable for a bit oh my god watch
this are you sure you see any are you
watching in a way that you can see
comments somewhere yeah little bit
real quick everybody how many of you are
doing video now like it but hated it at
first go give me a yes I promise you
you're about to be blown away so many
people struggle at first yeah like
you're gonna see so many yeses right now
because like people I mean almost
everybody by the way actually most
people are mean look at this this is
[ __ ] ridiculous
yes yeah but I guess so my other quick
question though is because I have this
second plugin it's for like anxiety for
teens because I just you know a lot of
kids are you need to make three videos a
day on tech talk about anxiety for teens
for a few months and then when you put
the book out I'll [ __ ] sell like
crazy this is why we're having this
convoy yeah but do you think do you
think like there's a difference between
like self-publishing or traditional or
it doesn't matter no both win both lose
yeah I think nobody knows where the [ __ ]
you are and then when you try to sell
something it's hard to sell yeah because
the problem is is like I've gotten a lot
of feedback over the years I'm like oh I
love your stuff I love your stuff but
then I'm like but it's not showing in
sales or it's not showing in like
numbers you know I mean I'm like what
the [ __ ] am I doing wrong what you're
doing wrong is not building a personal
brand to leverage against yeah you know
well you're also crushing this video
conversation everyone's going crazy
thank you seriously don't don't do this
to yourself yeah
I want you to make two to three [ __ ]
I want you to do two to three [ __ ]
videos on tick-tock a day about anxiety
and you'll [ __ ] every look like in
three months you'll have a real audience
of young adults that there I want to buy
your book yeah like we're [ __ ] in the
prime moment of being able to get to
that audience because of tick-tock like
it's a [ __ ] gift you won't open the
[ __ ] gift it's a just you know I was
starting to play with it a little bit
and put out like I'd put like you know
I'm just messing with it to join get it
out there trying you're not putting
yourself in it no not necessarily but
like I mean I posted one I got like 400
views this shit's insane so what the
[ __ ] are we doing here I don't what's
your Instagram it's travel Jersey girl
but it's spelled J erz okay bro that
doesn't find that pin that I want
everybody to how many followers do you
have
I like 1850 I think good let's get that
up so there's no it's j e RZ no why no
why dustin what are you from I'm
actually from Edison New Jersey I'm from
the same town that's amazing what'd you
go to and do you know he spelled it
wrong I know he's a [ __ ] Justin um do
you know I was in high school yeah I
would I would have went to JP Stevens oh
we didn't like you I know I'm aware but
good news I played before high school
200 and Counting so 100 in high school
okay Laura listen to me you may have a
huge [ __ ] mistake yeah all right well
right like we need to talk this through
no I mean listen I mean we're all [ __ ]
quarantine so I have nothing but time so
I might as well just say [ __ ] it and try
it right
look everybody Beth wants to follow you
so bad like people want to yeah listen
to me
you have your Jersey girl you can do
this we add up it going through Edison
High is way harder than [ __ ] making a
tick-tock
well I also because I feel like I
resonate with you so much because we're
from Jersey and I knew you were from
Jersey somehow cuz that like the curse
thing in like the Jersey news I'm like
not on he's from Jersey but like I also
feel like that could I'm sure you've had
the same thing where it's like I you
shouldn't curse so much behind you but
yes that was like that's neat about them
directly I promise you you be fully you
on tick-tock three times a day really
get into the culture of takes out what
kind of videos make and you [ __ ]
Laura listen to me these young girls and
guys need you yeah don't do this for me
don't do this for you know do that for
them I mean this do for them
yeah now you have 2045 followers on
Instagram what's your tick-tock it's the
same thing travel Jersey girl across the
board
twitter twitter same do you have a
youtube I do not but I have you don't
make good Maus no no I tried back in the
day I tried and I was like nah [ __ ] that
I'm not about it listen I yeah listen to
me I'm telling you this is this this
moment was for this yeah yeah Korona
happened so we could talk I
I agree so good yeah you're [ __ ]
Jersey girl you should not have a
problem with this I mean that I know do
this no tell me some real [ __ ] tell me
why you're not doing it is there
anything I'm not think about like weird
stalker boyfriend [ __ ] you're not bad
I'm being really real-life I want you to
win so I want to know it's just like
unconscious it's just uncomfortable
honest I think you I think intuitively I
think you can break through yeah and I
honestly think it's just like a like and
Laura real quick before you finish yeah
cuz I want everybody hears I swear to
God I don't do this all the time there's
a lot of calls I do there's a lot of
people interact with I don't push them
all the time because I don't always
think they can there's a weird [ __ ]
out there you know they're not good
they're not good but I really think you
can do this yeah I mean because I want
like with my books too because I
struggle with anxiety too so it's just
like it's very personal to me so I just
feel like between me I need you to be
more vulnerable in your videos then and
put me out tik-tok help these kids yeah
okay I'm telling you right now you can't
imagine how huge you can get on
tick-tock with this truth with this
Jersey Ness yeah like once you get going
like yeah I talked to somebody the other
day and she's a little bit more of a
optimal content creator literally took
her for hours she DM me she's like you
[ __ ] change the game for me already
I'm like voice impressions different
things are social [ __ ] going on there
yeah I think you can find your spot I'm
telling you all right I believe what are
you gonna do it or you like [ __ ]
right now I will I mean I'm not gonna
lie are you I am very uncomfortable
about trying to do it but I'm gonna play
with it and see and just I mean I have
nothing to lose it this is what's gonna
happen you're like [ __ ] you're like
best friend from the college you me like
all you [ __ ] suck it take time to
listen then that's what I believe like
I'm systematically going through the
cliche reasons one doesn't
yeah I'm personally no I'm not stuck I
almost feel like like you just [ __ ]
decide it yeah yeah alright things
change right yeah you can undecide yeah
Lord do this please yeah do me a favor
promise me this because everyone's
following you right now and so they're
gonna tell me tomorrow that you [ __ ]
I know yeah it's over [ __ ] now we've got
everyone's watching everybody's
following everyone's following you now
so tomorrow they're all gonna be back
cuz I'm back tomorrow I'm about to wrap
up here at 9 a.m. I can't wait to see
all of you back we're all following you
yeah I'm gonna put my whole team on it
no Brent right I need you to make two or
three tic TOCs today and two or three
Instagram make an Instagram video where
you just talk about things okay you can
do this I'm uncomfortable as [ __ ] but
okay I'd like that because the most
uncomfortable is [ __ ] [ __ ] usually leads
to the best [ __ ] yeah
by the way they need to hear you yeah
you can help them do you understand that
if you get serious about tick-tock
you're gonna save a child's life yeah I
know I mean it's
well you're not saving [ __ ] with 65
[ __ ] books sold on [ __ ] Amazon
Laura hey well yes you are you looking
at me do you understand right now yeah
so here's what's really gonna happen
listen to me you know one tick-tock you
go [ __ ] ham you're gonna build a real
[ __ ] audience I promise you I can
feel it with my whole [ __ ] soul
mm-hmm
those hey you're gonna save kids lives
in that content be
a bunch of them I'm gonna buy books when
she's gonna make you happy because
you've been wanting to be a [ __ ]
writer for your whole life and there's
gonna be a [ __ ] self-fulfilling
prophecy of the [ __ ] good versus you
decided you don't do it and nothing
[ __ ] happens right I mean in those 64
books you know [ __ ] a half of the
people that bought it yeah yeah two
thirds yeah okay Lou bought [ __ ] 20
of them mm-hmm so let's [ __ ] get
series here Laura okay
tick tock to the [ __ ] face
okay I mean I don't even know what the
hell I would say but I'm gonna tell you
what to do right now okay you're gonna
go in right now literally hang up and
watch three four hours of tick-tock
literally watch click the trending
topics go in your feed for you page and
just watch watch watch watch you're
gonna see trends you mean the commode
everyone's doing this okay my way of
talking about that through the lens of
anxiety I'm gonna make this video you're
gonna [ __ ] figure it out I believe in
you you're creative okay all right all
right well thank you so much you're
welcome so much and then she took action
I'm legit cringing as I make this but uh
thank you for everyone for your support
it's overwhelming um I promise to make
videos no idea what they'll be you guys
are awesome and I can I think Gary Vee
for giving me that opportunity so uh
[Music]
to just push me to keep going and to
stuff that's uncomfortable and
vulnerable and that's all what I'm about
and I'm just here to let people know
that uncomfortable [ __ ] can be done
doesn't doing this right now and I'm
cringing but and you know shit's crazy
and crazy I don't know we'll see where
this [ __ ] goes so I'm just riding
this [ __ ] wave that Gary Vee just
created because I know you [ __ ] will
destroy me if I don't do this
so again just very grateful for what
he's done and again we'll see where this
goes and you know [ __ ] quarantined
and bored as [ __ ] so let's do this [ __ ]
see
[Music]